there's a number of bitcoin metrics that
are all starting to develop laying the
groundwork for absolute rocket fuel for
the future bitcoin price one of the
beautiful things about bitcoin is that
you don't have to believe you can simply
go right to the on-chain metrics you can
see what's happening who owns bitcoin
how much when did they buy and what are
they doing with it these on-chain
metrics are only available in the
bitcoin and crypto ecosystem wall street
doesn't have this level of granularity
and they don't have this type of data to
analyze for their assets if we go and
take a look as i mentioned there is
rocket fuel being poured into what is
likely to be an explosion in the bitcoin
price in the coming weeks the first
thing is that miners have been
accumulating aggressively since april of
2021 we can see here with the balance in
the miner wallets they continue to buy
bitcoin they are not sellers but buyers
if we then look at how much bitcoin is
actually on the exchanges the less
bitcoin on the exchange the less people
can go ahead and sell it and what we see
is that about 61 000 bitcoin have been
taken off exchanges in the last three or
four weeks that is very very bullish for
bitcoin and future price appreciation
and then lastly if we take a look our
friend will clemente pointing out that
the illiquid supply shock ratio is going
vertical that blue line continues to go
up and up and up and as will says here
he says that supply continues to get
absorbed by entities with a low
statistical history of spending their
bitcoin the long-term holders the strong
hands they're soaking up all of the
bitcoin in the market they don't sell
they understand the value proposition of
bitcoin and they are going to make
anyone else who wants to come into the
market pay a much higher price to get
that bitcoin back from them as supply
becomes more illiquid all we need is a
catalyst to kick off the frenzy and this
is exactly what has happened multiple
times in the history of bitcoin
parabolic moves are followed after we
see this type of data set on the
on-chain metrics hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time